- We're back with our Moms
Timeout, our first one ever,
with Janna, whose story went viral
after posting this pic of her son Ezra,
very frustrated on his first
day of virtual kindergarten.
It's heartbreaking, we all
related, it went viral.
And, we're just talking about being moms,
and you're trying to do it all
and doing your best and
holding your families together
during these times.
And I hope that anyone out there
who may be watching who's
going through this, too,
can just join in on this conversation,
because we're all trying
to juggle all of this.
How are you doing?
- A juggling act, for sure.
- How are you doing it?
- Ironically, my kids give me my strength.
They're my why.
They're my reason.
And they're my whole world,
even though motherhood is
like the hardest journey ever,
like you said, I wouldn't
have it any other way.
So I think we're just
taking one day at a time.
And some days you are doing great
and other days it's a challenge,
but you just have to take it day by day,
and give yourself a lot of grace.
- You said that really your kids,
while being the thing that sort of has to,
you have to give the most
life force to and output wise,
is the thing that gives you
the strength in order to do it.
And again, I'm just like,
that's what I'm talking about, Jana.
You say things in this way
that just make a relatable
light bulb go off.
- Thank you.
I think, like you said, all
moms can relate to that,
that they're our why,
they're our driving force.
- Well, I think that you've
done a tremendous thing
for people because we
feel better when we know
we're all in the boat together,
rather than in lonely
little canoes, disconnected.
And I thought yours was
so selfless and relatable.
And this is sort of, to me,
like the example of how
powerful sharing can be.
- Thank you so much.
That means a lot.
And that was the whole reason
behind sharing this photo
was I knew that, like I said,
all along that I'm not
gonna be the only one
going through this,
but seeing someone else post it,
and whether that's myself,
it just resonates with so many families
and that we just don't want
to feel alone in all of this,
'cause it can be a lonely time.
- May I ask what you said to Ezra
when you did see him crying?
You took the picture-
- Yeah.
- But then what was your,
what was your follow through, may I ask?
What's your advice?
- So I asked him to step
away from the computer,
and he came over by me,
and we actually sat on
the floor and just hugged.
And we both had tears,
but I told him that it's
not just hard for him.
It's hard for everybody,
that we're gonna get
through this together,
and that we're gonna just try our best,
but it was still really hard for him
to understand that this was his reality,
that it's gonna be on the computer,
because even the night before
he was sticking his shoes
out for the next day.
- I love that you said, let's
step away and take a break.
I think kids and adults can really benefit
from that kind of separation.
It changes and shifts our energy.
I mean, you're such a good mom, Jana.
What do you do to take care of yourself?
What do you do?
How do you,
how do you,
I know we all put our kids first,
but do you get to do things for yourself?
You're such a good mom.
- Oh, thank you.
So having four kids obviously
that leaves a lot less time for myself,
but before kids,
I was a competitive figure skater
and then turned coach.
So that was a huge part of my life.
And now where we live
the rink is an hour away.
With Atlanta traffic
it's even more than that.
So it's not reality for me right now,
but I hope to spark that passion
back in my life sometime.
- Oh gosh, yeah,
I think that would be
an amazing prescription
of getting back to,
also physical exertion is so positive
for the mental state
and the physical state,
for taking on all that you do as a mom.
God, I wanna get you back
and find time for you to figure skate.
- That would be amazing.
It's a huge hole in my heart right now,
but that's all right, because
there'll be time for it.
- Yeah, well, we have
a Moms Timeout surprise
called The PolyGlide Synthetic Ice Company
is gonna put a rink in your backyard.
- [Audience Member] What?
(audience cheering)
- What?
I'm like in shock right now.
- Apparently they just put one
in Justin Bieber's backyard,
so,
they know what they're doing.
(audience cheering)
- Wow.
- Yeah, and I can't thank-
- Thank you.
That's amazing.
- You deserve this.
And I wish that we could
all wave a magic wand
for one another.
And we were all so excited
and cheering and freaking out
that we could-
- My kids are gonna freak out.
- I know, they can use it, too.
- Yes.
- But this one's all about you, Jana.
You really deserve this.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for making
us all feel less alone,
more connected, and relate to each other.
I think your approach and your advice
and your tactics are fantastic.
And would it be okay if we,
once we built the skate
rink in your backyard,
we can come visit and like check it out
and see how it's going for you?
- Please, that would be amazing.
- Okay, all right (laughing).
Well you give us all strength
and we'll be checking back in on
how the progress is going
on your brand new ice skating
rink in your backyard.
(audience cheering)
- That's so cool.
- Well, thank you, Jana, so much.
(upbeat music)